all right we have a green flag question
what's up gc
hey how are you sir good man so can you
just clarify your question on the green
flecks so um
i've been with this girl for about a
little bit over two years now
and um
in the beginning i was she kind of met
me when i was first starting my business
so
didn't have a lot going on but i think
she understood that i had the potential
and uh okay how old are you i'm 28. okay
so uh just turned 29 sorry so uh
eventually um
i got there uh i've i've been
pretty successful for the past couple
years now and i started kind of getting
into the whole uh red pill stuff and
understanding more about um
kind of getting on frame and all these
things and
she's kind of there but there are times
where she kind of pushes back a little
bit
and and i try to wonder sometimes at
what point is it
worth to just like go and move on if you
see that she has all of the green flags
that you kind of mentioned pretty much
all of them you know father's still
there um low body count etc etc very
very feminine all those things okay so
i'm not sure i understand what the
challenge is so so sorry she's pushing
you in what area right like she's like
she's trying to make you better she's
trying to support you she's trying to
get you to be more successful like what
is the push for well she definitely does
all those things i think the the one
thing that she was not cool with for
example was
when i started bringing up fresh and fit
and stuff like that
um she she was completely against the
fact that
men are allowed to be with multiple
women and women are not just because of
the sense of like women tend to kind of
fall in love uh with men versus you know
men are are are we just we just you know
we just want to have sex for a lack of
[Music]
i'm in austin texas okay and you've been
with her for how long again a little bit
over two years so
another thing
uh one more thing we actually got
married um okay about six months ago or
so and and we've been on and off and and
she's
she uh she always um came back to me and
she actually even returned the ring etc
so she did all the things that showed me
that she wasn't with me for my money
okay and sorry she's how old
she is 27.
she's 27. she have any kids do you guys
have any kids together no no kids so you
so your question is how do i open up the
relationship because i want to bang
other checks basically right
uh well that would be one question and
then another would be you know at what
point do i say because i know obviously
the one itis and all those things come
come into place but also
understanding you know when you actually
do have a good woman and there are some
things that maybe you may need to um
to give a little bit of wiggle room on
buffs in the comedy says l-m-a-o yeah
bringing that fresh idea dude
you know you know how i say guys like to
complicate their life and justify why
yeah right like women don't want to know
how the game works they just want to
know that you're that you're playing it
and that they're participating in it
okay they don't want to know all the
moving parts it's like
are you a car car guy
uh
not necessarily i mean i have a alpha
romeo uh quadrifoglio that i've had for
a while and oh dude you're a car guy
anybody with an alpha is a car guy
okay so let me break it down for you a
internal combustion engine is basically
an air pump
there's valves there's springs there's
cam shafts there's pistons there's
piston rings there's tie rods
there's all these moving parts that work
you know collectively to basically suck
in air on one part blow it up in the
engine and spit it out the back end at
the tailpipe you have that conversation
with a woman her eyes glaze over yeah
okay you talk to a guy they're like yep
i know exactly what you're talking about
you don't talk to women women about red
pill stuff it just it just doesn't work
look i've done it we've all done it a
lot of guys in the chat i'm like yeah
i've done it they don't [ __ ] listen
you know they don't want to hear it they
don't want to know how things work they
just want to participate in the you know
the game so
i mean like the thing about
dating other women when you want her to
be exclusive to you because i mean
obviously you don't want to poison the
well because you're not a [ __ ] right
you're not like will smith who lets his
son's friend august bang your wife and
then you get pissed off and have to slap
some guy on the stage if you guys miss
that part go back to the start
you're not that guy right so you want
her to be exclusive to you but you want
to exercise your options you've watched
some other channels that make a big deal
about it here's the thing though dude
some women just don't go for it
they just won't i would say about a
third of women will just not have it a
third of women are totally fine with it
and then the other third are probably
persuadable
right so you got to figure out which
category she falls in i've seen a lot of
guys pull this off that you know they
just say look i love you
i don't want the
relationship to change i think you're
great i want to have children with you i
want to raise a family but
i need some strange from time to time so
i'm not going to embarrass you i'm not
going to bring i'm not going to do dates
there's going to be no woman showing up
in the front door with a baby that's
mine um i'm not gonna go to a restaurant
where your friends and family go and
they're gonna take a picture and say oh
look i see gc over here with this girl
what's he doing sort of thing to ruin
your day i'm not gonna do any of those
things it's gonna be very quiet it's
gonna be
no risk uh you know to your health i'm
just going to have some fun from time to
time
some of those women are cool with that
some of them are just going to be like
i'm not having it right and if she's not
having it and you want to have it you
have a choice to make you can either
choose monogamy or you can choose to be
non-monogamous and go outside the
relationship in some cases you know you
might have to leave the marriage in some
cases you just might have to cheat and
see if her love is real for you
sure
do you think at that point do you think
that's possible for somebody do you
think it's just because of my age that
i'm so young and obviously i'm just like
trying to [ __ ] you know pretty much
anything no
like
any
any guy walking the earth it doesn't
matter if he's 28 38 48 58 if he's
healthy and he sees a hot chick
the same thought that's going through
your mind is going through his mind sure
all right
great thank you so much men are men are
designed to conquer and spread seed okay
we get you know
when we shoot a load there's like
something like 200 million
sperm in there women get one egg per
month that's it
men and women are very different and
you're never ever going to convince a
woman that that doesn't think uh
otherwise to think otherwise they just
don't they're just totally plugged in
conditioned by society to think that
cheating is bad and even if you say to
them well
your other boyfriend's cheated on you
right well yeah well
like what are you going to do you're
going to leave me and go find some other
guys that's going to do the exact same
thing to you like are you stupid they'll
be like yes that's exactly what i'm
going to do right so
sure is what it is right you got to
you got to figure out where she's at
exactly if that's what it is that you
want to do yeah
all right all right see you man hey guys
i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you